come on then dairy cows they need a lot
of food and an awful lot of land usually
that's bad for the planet
now plans are a foot to produce a new
kind of dairy without a single udder
being squeezed
in East London they're using yeast to
brew the protein in milk much like you
would brew beer we then take these
reprogrammed yeasts and we put them in
these fermenters and that allows us to
brew large batches of the milk protein
casein and casein is what gives Cheez
it's melt its stretch its gooeyness they
add it to a plant-based to make their
own kind of cheese
it is molecularly identical to the
protein in milk but vegan and they say
it's just a safe prior to this you know
people tend to have to making a
trade-off really in terms of either
being sustainable or enjoying good food
so the idea behind what we're building
here is that we want to produce products
that taste as great as traditional Dairy
without using any animals as part of the
production process
this method of precision fermentation
isn't new it's already used to make
things like insulin and food supplements
but industry hopes it could
revolutionize food production because if
all Dairy and meat can be made in a lab
like this you don't need any farmland
and that matters because Dairy farming
and feed takes up the equivalent of 20
of UK land
but we're supposed to be eating 20 less
Dairy and meat to hit climate targets
industry says lab-grown Dairy can cut
emissions by up to 97 percent
but it could take years before lab-grown
meat and dairy hit the shells they need
approval first and although the industry
is expected to Boom products won't come
cheap
and some argue it's not about cutting
out meat and dairy instead eating less
but better quality there are a growing
number of cows in the UK who are
permanently housed indoors they're fed
on crops sometimes imported from
overseas and it's quite unsustainable
but actually there's a role for rooting
animals for cows they can contribute to
soil Health if grazed appropriately they
can help manage habitats but if we Farm
like that in a more nature friendly way
we're not going to produce as much dairy
or cheese as we do today
so whether we are eating less or an
alternative as long as we're facing a
nature crisis scientists say something
about the way we eat has to change
Victoria Seabrook Sky News